mesdames et messieurs public toute
éthique ce soir bonsoir
vous êtes là ça tombe bien je vais avoir
besoin de vous je suis très heureuse
d'être ici ce soir pour vous raconter la
formidable aventure citoyenne du
mouvement des incroyables comestibles il
est possible que vous ayez déjà entendu
parler de notre mouvement participatif
citoyens est ce que vous pourriez lever
la main à ceux qui ont déjà entendu
parler des incroyables comestibles au
bon c'est pas un carton plein mais pas
loin
je voudrais vous parler de l'expérience
que je vis depuis plus de cinq ans
maintenant depuis plus 50 les
incroyables comestibles sont implantés
en france
s'agit d'un mouvement participatif
citoyens notre mode d'action est très
simple nous proposons nous invitons les
citoyens à faire des plantations
partagés sur l'espace public
ces plantations elles sont librement
accessibles à toutes et à tous
elles sont librement mise en partage le
thème d un crop comestibles c'est celui
de la nourriture mais de la nourriture
qui se partagent ce que je voudrais moi
partager ce soir c'est plus mon aventure
personnelle liée aux incroyables
comestibles il se trouve que depuis cinq
ans je vis l'expérience au quotidien de
l'infini pouvoir des petites actions et
c'est de cela que je n que j'aimerais
témoigner devant vous ce soir juste
avant peut-être deux modes d'hubert
reeves que vous connaissez tous
astrophysicien célèbre hubert reeves
disait il ya trois questions
existentielles dans la vie vous les
connaissez sans doute la première je
vous écoute
pardon qui suis-je
la seconde non d'où je viens la
troisième en effet du beige et
figurez-vous que hubert reeves
astrophysicien français célèbre et de
renom a été contredit par woody allen
c'est quand même quelque chose
les woody allen a prétendu qu'il y avait
une quatrième question existentielle
il la formule de la façon suivante et
sinon ce soir qu'est ce qu'on mange
l'histoire des incroyables comestibles
c'est l'histoire d'une mobilisation
citoyenne en réalité nous présentons les
incollables comestible pour ce qu'ils
sont c'est à dire le mouvement des gens
ordinaires simple citoyen du monde
il se trouve qu'en tant que cofondateur
du mouvement en france j'ai l'occasion
de me déplacer dans tout le pays et
également à l'étranger pour raconter
cette aventure citoyenne et quelquefois
on me demande mais êtes-vous
[Musique]
nutritionniste vous qui parlez
l'alimentation ou est-ce que vous êtes
ingénieur agronome vous qui parlez du
lien à la terre des terres des cultures
et là je leur réponds je suis juste jean
michel et jean michel père de famille
quatre enfants j'habite en alsace dans
une jolie vallée vosgienne et ce dont je
témoigne c'est juste du pouvoir des
petites actions
quand on fait sa part et qu'on invite en
faisant sa part d'autre à faire la leur
tout simplement
donc je n'interviens jamais comme un
expert parce que je ne suis expert de
rien sinon du fait que je suis un
citoyen et avant même d'être un simple
citoyen je suis un être humain comme
nous tous ici dans cette salle
voyez les manceaux disait la guerre est
une chose trop sérieuse trop engageante
pour la laisser entre les mains des
militaires
et bien moi je me dis la question de la
nourriture de l'alimentation ce qui nous
nourrit au quotidien et ce qui nous
nourrit véritablement c'est quand même
une affaire trop sérieuse pour la
laisser aux experts et c'est important
que chacun d'entre nous prenne
conscience du pouvoir que nous avons
quand nous nous réapproprions notre
alimentation
alors on pourrait passer beaucoup de
temps à parler de l'alimentation moderne
des circuits mondialisée notre
alimentation des taux je sais pas des
rentes qui se déterminent sur les
marchés boursiers internationaux de nos
aliments qui font des milliers de
kilomètres
quelquefois avant d'arriver dans nos
assiettes ma conviction en tant que
simple citoyen mc à un peu investi
qu'est le sujet
c'est que je crois que le l'alimentation
est juste un enjeu de civilisation
avons nous conscience que quand nous
mangeons
en réalité nous absorbons quelque chose
qui ressemblerait à une vibration moyen
facile à comprendre en réalité et puis
on est où on est en 2010 est on à la
physique quantique qui nous parle de la
vibration ne dit que tout est vibration
et bien moi j'ai fait le constat c'est
une intuition que quand on est c
corroborée par ailleurs par quelques
études c'est que quand vous cueillez la
pomme sur l'arbre et vous la mangez
immédiatement alors elle a une saveur si
vous mettez la pompe dans le panier et
vous la mangez trois heures plus tard
alors cette saveur juste un petit peu
plus différente parce que la vibration
de l'organisme vivant vous mangez à ce
moment-là a juste baisser un petit peu
imaginer mesdames et messieurs que cette
pomme au lieu d'être mangés
immédiatement ou au lieu d'être mise
dans le panier elle rentre dans le
processus industriel et qu'elle se
transforme en compote de pommes
industriels
que reste-t-il donc de cette vibration
est ce qu on pourrait admettre
aujourd'hui à l'aune de toutes les
études et tous les progrès de la science
qui vont dans l'infiniment petit et dans
l'état vibratoire des choses est ce qu
on pourrait admettre que notre
nourriture ce qui nous nourrit
véritablement alors certes c'est l'amour
mais on se grandit veut c'est
véritablement la vibration de ce qu'on
mange est alors bien une question qui
m'est venue et la question est la
suivante comment pouvons-nous manger une
nourriture réellement vivante qui est
produite dans des sols qui sont juste
mort aujourd'hui
chemiser ya même plus de vers de terre
vous imaginez alors ces questions là
elles sont traitées dans le mouvement
des incroyables comestibles je vais vous
en parler mais avant on a peu de temps à
passer ensemble on a peu de temps pour
faire l'amour ensemble mesdames et
messieurs ce soir alors havrais après
ces quelques préliminaires
j'aimerais venir à l'essentiel de ce que
j'ai à vous dire
et l'essentiel de ce que j'ai à vous
dire c'est que vous êtes super mesdames
et messieurs je crois avoir compris
cartes lx dunkerque il faut le faire
deux fois je vais leur dire mesdames et
messieurs vous êtes super madame qui est
juste devant moi comment vous
appelez-vous oui juste groupe renault ne
vous retournez pas dominique vous êtes
super pas applaudir dominique a et
monsieur au premier rang comment vous
appelez laurent vous êtes super mesdames
qui est ici ce soir intel x dunkerque
vous êtes super et messieurs on voudrait
tous ces supers et maintenant j'aurai
une petite demande à vous faire est ce
que ça vous dirait de me faire plaisir
on va le refaire
est ce que ça vous dirait de me faire
très plaisir mesdames et messieurs
ok alors s'il vous plaît tournez vous
vers votre voisin ouvert votre voisine
et dites lui qu'il ou elle est super
ça le fait un sale fait vraiment un
alors j'ai une proposition vous faire et
la proposition c'est que je vais vous
emmener dans une rue à paris et ensuite
on reprendra le cours normal de cette
conférence et de ce pitch sur les
incroyables comestibles a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
c'est un super photographe monsieur
c'est cadeau
vous êtes super
bah oui oui je n'en doute pas je suis
certain que ça super merci bien sûr que
c'est pour vous êtes super merci bien
sûr que ça gratuit vous êtes super
fava twitté sava instagram et bonne
journée vous êtes super
bon ben voilà on est tous raison je suis
d'accord pas c'est gentil ça fait
plaisir
merci beaucoup saluent j'adore ta
gasquet n
magnifique
et belt à trottinette j'adore d'entrée
chars
merci
jouée par faire une
allez bien joué ça
m
vous savez je savais pas c'est vous qui
êtes hyper dk
au soudan
assalé de ses chances des compliments
des choses gentilles est superbe
très élégant de sion
je fais les compléments gratuit qui
passe à merci
cette superbe
c'est une photo parfaite
pas mal nos gentils
[Musique]
oui vous êtes super
la démarche
pour y décharger une
vous êtes super moselle
oh merci
[Musique]
jourdan même style
vous êtes super votre chapeau est
sublime
pourquoi
saleh
je vois
en
au revoir
[Musique]
salut super bowl
attaque on
[Musique]
super
ed
[Musique]
je t'aime
de nos jours
[Musique]
gardez votre sourire merci un peu
d'amour
merci
[Musique]
un gros merci à vous un grand merci à
grégoire et à toute l'équipe de vous
êtes super de nous avoir autorisés à
projeter cette magnifique vidéo ce soir
ici à dunkerque
en fait la sphère est très sérieuse
mesdames et messieurs nous sommes super
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nous
portons en nous des dispositions qui
nous permettent de créer l'harmonie dans
ce monde en tant qu'êtres humains nous
avons les dispositions antérieures qui
nous permettent de générer quelque chose
qui soit de l'ordre de l'harmonie de
l'entente de la relation à l'autre
de l'appréhension du monde à partir de
ces dispositions intérieur donc super ça
c'est donner ses acquis d'accord mais
dans la vie on peut être aussi en fête -
super alors ça ça contredit le premier
postulat c'est possible qu'on ait oublié
qu'on est super dans la vie on peut être
aussi mesdames et messieurs
on peut être
mesdames et messieurs dans la vie on
peut être aussi incroyable incroyable
comestibles et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire d'être incroyable comestibles et
bien ça veut dire de juste avoir envie
de faire sa part pour révéler aux gens
qui sont super d'accord poser des actes
au quotidien qui vont rayonner cette
réalité là d'accord est-ce qu'on
pourrait avoir à nouveau le powerpoint
oui merci si vous choisissiez mesdames
et messiers de devenir infiniment
incroyable dans votre vie voilà à quoi
ça ressemble
l'expérience que je vous raconte c'est
l'expérience de ma famille les premières
actions incroyable comestibles ont eu
lieu en angleterre puisque c'est
l'expérience berceau de la ville de
tonnes mort donne dans le yorkshire d'où
est parti il est d'où sont partis les
accroît comestibles mais en france ce
sont dans mon village avec ma famille
avec mes amis avec mes voisins que nous
avons lancé les premières actions
incroyable comestibles en france vous
avez très certainement entendu parler de
ce mouvement parce que nous avons été
considérablement relayées par la presse
et des grands médias
on en est très honoré naturellement on a
eu des articles juste énorme
on a eu des articles sur les accroître
comestible mouvement anti crise
on a eu des articles qui me parlait des
accroches comestibles comme le tenez
vous bien le phénomène génial qui
contamine la france j'aurais préféré
qu'on dit de phénomènes génial qui
pollinisent la france m'enfin bon on a
même eu un article
tenez vous encore mieux qui présentait
cette notion de la gratuité et le titre
était les incroyables comestibles l'an
zéro du sceau de civilisation excusez
moi du peu
alors pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça
mais ça donne c'est parce que quand on
lance des actions dans son village
d'alsace
alors on peut conquérir la france nous
n'étions jamais que des citoyens
ordinaires
une famille des enfants on associer les
grands parents les amis les voisins et
on a fait des bacs de plantation
incroyable comestibles le principe vous
le connaissez servez-vous librement
c'est gratuit
et entre temps partout en france nous
avons des groupes citoyens qui se sont
mobilisés en notre nom des accroches
comestible pour faire leur part dans ce
processus qui vise à faire jaillir une
nouvelle réalité nourricière une
nouvelle préoccupation selon laquelle
nous pouvons être nous-mêmes m reprendre
la main nous réapproprier notre
nourriture ici vous avez des très belles
installations à clermont ferrand
et si vous voyez les incroyables
comestibles de montréal puisque entre
temps parti d'angleterre arrivé en
france et présent aujourd'hui dans plus
de 600 villes et villages notre
mouvement est présent sur tous les
continents dans 25 pays
notre pancarte à nous ya pas marqué vous
êtes super dessus qui a marqué ce que
vous voyez derrière nourriture à
partager servez-vous librement c'est
gratuit le principe même c'est que nous
posons un acte qui a pour objectif de
rayonner une autre réalité
une autre possibilité pourquoi ça
s'appelle les incroyables comestibles
peut-être parce que ensemble dans
l'énergie citoyenne des gens ordinaires
les mamans des papas les enfants les
grands parents nous essayons de créer la
co-création joyeuse de l'abondance
partager la formule est belle n'est ce
pas mais peut-être plus que ça quand ces
gens ordinaires vous racontent leur
expérience d'incroyables comestibles et
qui vous dise
concrètement ce qui se passe sur le
terrain alors on vous dit c'est simple
on a commencé à faire ça puis on a fait
ça et puis ensuite on a fait ça et
ensuite en là c'était vraiment
incroyable il s'est passé ça ça ça et ça
et quand ça se passe comme ça
vous vivez la magie à partir du moment
où les gens se reconnecte entre eux et
se reconnecte à la terre nourricière
il ya un processus magique derrière des
incroyables de comestible d'accord
toutes ces personnes qui sont désireuses
de créer une nouvelle réalité un nouveau
monde une nouvelle humanité et qui ont
imaginé que la nourriture était vraiment
le point de départ pour une raison
simple cette raison c'est que la
nourriture nous unit mesdames et
messieurs
pour une raison simple c'est que chaque
jour au moins deux ou trois fois par
jour tous nous devons nous nourrir nous
n'avons pas peur de la nourriture de
l'autre le mouvement des incroyables
comestible est un mouvement qui cherche
à créer l'unité à rapprocher les gens à
les accepter tels qu'ils sont comme ils
sont là où ils sont mais aussi à les
inviter à faire la part alors par et les
inviter à être eux-mêmes le changement
qui veulent voir dans le monde en
commençant par réfléchir à la façon de
se nourrir et surtout en posant un acte
gratuit et désintéressé qui consiste à
faire des plantations
et les offrir à chacun c'est ce qu'on
appelle mesdames et messieurs un
mouvement de biens communs voici les
fondatrices
les deux mères de famille de cette ville
du nord de l'angleterre
gordon qui ont lancé les ipad
comestibles je tiens à leur rendre
hommage et en angleterre on parle de
foot touchèrent attitude figurez vous
c'est quoi la foule touchèrent attitude
va tous chers nourriture à
partager ça devient nourriture sa pièce
devient un style de vie et ça devient
aussi la marque des simples gens qui
veulent juste rayonner une nouvelle
réalité de conscience un autre domaine
de possibles images et le monde de
demain et fait ressurgir les
alternatives autour de l'alimentation la
nourriture saine local bio respectueuse
des soli du vivant notre utopie imaginer
qu'on puisse nourrir l'humanité d'une
façon saine pour l'homme et pour la
planète dans la joie et dans la dignité
de chacun on a droit d'avoir des utopies
mais la nôtre elle commence dans sa
réalisation
devant chez nous voici à quoi ressemble
une livre qui se transforment ou une
nouvelle nuit une nouvelle réalité
nourricière surgi au coeur de nos villes
vous êtes ici à tout demandeur partout
partout dans la ville des plantations
partagé y compris devant le commissariat
de police
deux grandes vagues lunettes râteau
d'andenne lui m sur 1 m 50
d'accord cette photo a fait le tour du
monde mesdames et messieurs
regardez un peu à quoi ça ressemble la
co-création joyeuse avons nous partager
nous avons beaucoup d'action dans les
écoles les enfants ceux liés à cette
réalité nord-isère figure
et vous mesdames et messieurs que selon
une étude récente que j'ai eus entre les
mains récemment donc quatre enfants sur
5 d'aujourd'hui ne savent plus
distinguer une courgette d'un poireau
d'une aubergine quelle planète à laisser
à nos enfants
mais quel enfant elles vont nous laisser
à notre planète
nous avons beaucoup d'action dans les
écoles nous avons aussi beaucoup
d'action dans les maisons de retraite et
on est très très heureux quand les
simples gens s'unissent pour remettre
les mains dans la terre nourricière et
pour faire surgir une nouvelle réalité
d'abondance la ville de demain c'est
notre conviction et sera autosuffisant
sur le plan énergétique
mais elle sera aussi autosuffisant sur
le plan alimentaire et à cela nous
pouvons tous être des personnes actives
et engagées
regardez l'énergie du nouveau monde
regardez mesdames et messieurs le vrai
visage de la france
le visage du talent de la générosité du
coeur et du partage
quand on se dégage de nos peurs cantons
rpt et accède à sa propre souveraineté
quand par le fait d'actions qui nous
permet de nous réapproprier l'espace
public on se réapproprie à soi-même et
compose des choix par des
questionnements sur notre nourriture
notre éducation sont d'autres façons de
nous soigner nous déplacer alors on fait
surgir un autre visage de la france
regardez ces belles énergies nourricière
ils sont actives dans nos vies l'uci à
albi c'est ça les accros comme cible
c'est l'énergie du nouveau monde
les belles énergies sont notre avenir
mesdames et messieurs multiplions les
les croyants au pouvoir à l'infini
pouvoir des petites actions
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]